>> Tucker: ONE OF THE
REASONS IT LOOKS LIKE THE
PEOPLE THAT CURRENTLY RUN
THE GOVERNMENT ARE ABOUT
TO BE REPUDIATED IN
HISTORIC WAY NEXT TUESDAY
IS THAT THEY HAVE
COMPLETELY OPENED THE
SOUTHERN BORDER OVER WHICH
MORE THAN 5 MILLION
FOREIGN NATIONALS HAVE
COME IN AND BROKEN LAWS BY
DOING IT.
THE SITUATION AT THE
BORDER IS NOT GETTING
BETTER, YOU WOULD THINK IT
WOULD WITH ELECTION
COMING, BUT IT IS WORSE.
BILL MELUGIN HAS AMAZING
FOOTAGE FOR US.
HEY, BILL.
>> HEY, TUCKER, THAT'S
RIGHT.
THE ILLEGAL CROSSINGS DOWN
HERE IN EAGLE PASS AREA
ARE NONSTOP.
WE HAD AN ABSOLUTELY
ENORMOUS GROUP CROSS THIS
MORNING.
WANT TO SHOW YOU
REMARKABLE DRONE FOOTAGE
THE TEAM SHOT BEFORE THE
SUN CAME UP.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS THERMAL
CAPABLE DRONE SHOWING
SEVERAL HUNDRED MIGRANTS
CROSSING INTO NORMANDY,
TEXAS, A TINY TOWN ON THE
OUTSKIRTS OF EAGLE PASS.
AS ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COME
IN, THEY SNAKE IN THROUGH
THE BRUSH AFTER CROSSING
THE RIO GRANDE.
A SOURCE TELLING US AS OF
THIS MORNING IN A 24 HOUR
SPAN IN THIS SECTOR, THERE
WERE MORE THAN 1700
ILLEGAL CROSSINGS.
YOU CAN SEE FROM THE VIDEO
ALMOST ALL OF THE PEOPLE
COMING IN ARE SINGLE
ADULTS, HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK TO A LOT OF THEM AS
THEY WALKED UP, MOSTLY
FROM CUBA, COLOMBIA,
NICARAGUA, URAGUAY AND
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
YOU SEE THEM WALKING IN
SINGLE FILE LINE, WILLING
TO SURRENDER TO BORDER
PATROL.
THEY DO THAT BECAUSE THEY
KNOW ONCE THEY STEP FOOD
IN THE UNITED STATES UNDER
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
THEY'RE LIKELY RELEASED
INTO THE UNITED STATES
RATHER THAN REMOVED FROM
THE COUNTRY.
WE HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
A LOT OF MIGRANTS WALKING
UP FOR PROCESSING, ASKED
THEM A SIMPLE QUESTION IN
SPANISH.
DO YOU BELIEVE THE BORDER
IS OPEN OR IS IT CLOSED.
EVERYBODY WHO TALKED TO US
LAUGHED AND SMILED AND
SAID I DIDN'T TELL OPEN, I
DIDN'T TELL -- IT'S OPEN,
IT'S OPEN.
WE SEE GROUPS LIKE THIS
EVERY SINGLE DAY OUT HERE
IN THE EAGLE PASS AREA.
TO PUT IT IN PERSPECTIVE
FOR YOU, WE HAD A GROUP IN
THE SAME SPOT YESTERDAY,
AND YESTERDAY IN A ONE
HOUR SPAN HAD MORE THAN
800 ILLEGAL CROSSINGS.
BACK HERE LIVE, A CBP
SOURCE SAYS THERE HAVE
BEEN 46,000 ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS, NOT INCLUDING
THE THOUSANDS OF KNOWN GET
AWAYS.
>> GREATEST CRIME
COMMITTED AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES, BY FAR.
NOTHING HAS COME CLOSE TO
WHAT WE ARE SEEING NOW.
NO ONE HAS REPORTED ON IT
MORE
MORE THAN YOU.
I WANT TO SHOW REPORTING
FOR THE DOCUMENTARY BATTLE
FOR THE BORDER ON FOX
NATION.
HERE'S A CLIP.
STAY THERE.
I WANT TO PUT THIS UP.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
ILLEGAL ALIENS COMING
ACROSS EVERY MONTH ONLY
MAKE IT EASIER FOR CARTELS
TO SMUGGLE DRUGS THROUGH
THE BIG BEN SECTOR.
>> SMUGGLERS LOVE THIS
AREA, IT IS SO OPEN, SO
REMOTE, SO EASY TO HIDE,
NOT AS MANY BORDER PATROL
AGENTS LOOKING FOR THEM.
>> Tucker: RESOURCES ARE
ALREADY STRETCHED THIN.
CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION AND DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC SAFETY HAVE
CAMERAS THROUGH THE DESERT
TO IDENTIFY ILLEGAL
CROSSERS, BUT THE
TECHNOLOGY ISN'T ENOUGH.
THE ONLY WAY TO STOP
DEADLY DRUGS FROM ENTERING
THIS COUNTRY IS HUNTING
SMUGGLERS IN PERSON.
ON THE GROUND, IN THE
FIELD.
ABANDONED DRUG BUNDLES
LITTER THE DESERT FLOOR,
DITCHED BY SMUGGLERS THAT
HEAR LAW ENFORCEMENT
HELICOPTERS OVERHEAD.
AFTER HIDING DRUGS, THIS
HE BLEND IN WITH IMMIGRANT
GROUPS TO GET AWAY SCOTT
FREE.
>> SERGEANT MORRIS DECIDED
HE WANTED TO FIND DRUG
BUNDLES.
>> Tucker: HE JOINED A
MISSION TO RECOVER BUNDLES
WITH SORJ MORRIS.
>> WE INVESTIGATE, GET TWO
BUNDLES WITH 100 POUNDS OF
MARIJUANA.
>> LOOK LIKE WORTH LANDING
FOR SURE.
THERE IT IS.
FROM THE AIR COULD SEE A
SQUARE.
>> HOW THE HELL DID YOU
SEE IT FROM THE AIR?
>> DOING IT AWHILE, THE
EYE IS STRAINED.
HAVEN'T SEEN A SQUARE ROCK
BEFORE.
HE THIS BREAK IN, WE ARE
LOOKING AROUND HERE.
SHOULD BE ANOTHER BUNDLE
HERE.
>> I FW THROUGH TSA
TOMORROW, DRUG DOGS WILL
LIGHT ME UP.
>> COME UP HERE.
THERE YOU GO.
THERE IT IS.
YEAH.
AWESOME.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> BUT PERFECTLY INTACT,
GOOD CONDITION HERE.
LOOK AT THAT.
>> WE'RE GOING TO PULL THE
DUCT TAPE OFF.
SHOOT.
HOLY SMOKES, WHAT HAVE WE
GOT.
>> Tucker: WE'VE DONE THE
STORY SO MANY TIMES, BUT
PICTURES ARE STILL
STUNNING.
BILL, PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL
TWO YEARS IN LIVING NEXT
TO THIS DAY TO DAY, WHAT
IS THEIR VIEW OF THE
BORDER RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, THEY'RE
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THEY
FEEL LIKE IT IS JUST
GETTING WORSE AND WORSE
AND NUMBERS BACK THAT UP.
FISCAL YEAR '21 BROKE THE
RECORD WITH 1.7 MILLION
ILLEGAL CROSSINGS.
THEN WE BROKE THE RECORD
AGAIN IN FISCAL 2022 WITH
2.4 MILLION CROSSINGS AND
THERE'S BEEN NO ACTION, NO
CHANGE IN POLICY FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION, AND THE
NUMBERS DON'T EVEN COUNT
FOR THE KNOWN GOT AWAYS.
WE ARE PUSHING OVER #
MILLION KNOWN GOT AWAYS
SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE, THAT'S WHAT BORDER
PATROL AGENTS ARE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT, IT IS NOT
THE FAMILIES OR PEOPLE
WILLING TO TURN THEMSELVES
IN.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN BIG
GROUPS COME ACROSS, BORDER
PATROL AGENTS ARE SUCKED
UP HAVING TO PROCESS THEM,
AND THEN BAD ACTORS AND
DRUGS SLIP IN ELSEWHERE
ALONG THE BORDER, TUCKER?
>> Tucker: AND NO ONE IN
WASHINGTON CARES.
I WISH DeSANTIS WOULD SEND
10,000 MORE TO BETHESDA.
WAKE THOSE PEOPL